the media loves repetition repeat the
same story again and again and like
beetlejuice
the story appears right now right now
there's the ukraine refrain
where opinions about a phone call
actually drown out its actual words
another day another smoking gun it is
definitely a smoking gun ukraine was a
smoking gun the bombshell text message
is what they revealed
came out to defend the initial bombshell
this is shaping up obviously yet another
political bombshell an impeachable
offense what is the standard of an
impeachable offense
that is an impeachable offense it's like
they have the same script
it's sad the same media that made
benghazi a punchline
shake with rage over a phone call that
came with a transcript
and then there's syria the president is
abandoning the kurds
and selling out the kurds we are now
abandoning the kurds
abandoning the kurds abandoning our
allies and this president just abandons
them the abandonment of kurdish allies
if we're backing away from our
commitment to the kurds
where do they turn well that was
alarmingly
identical so those who feared this
president would lead us into wars are
now upset he's moving 50
to 100 troops just like the people who
hated hawkish john bolton
but then were outraged when he bolted
because trump wasn't hawkish enough
of course we know trump's a dove he
favors trade wars over real ones
and delighted in removing north korea's
reasons for paranoia
it's almost like trump has a consistent
if not always artful
point of view we're getting out of the
endless wars
it's a quagmire we're up to close to
eight trillion dollars
and we're bringing our folks back home
we're now acting as
police we're we're policing areas
we're doing jobs that other countries
should be doing the hardest thing i have
to do
by far much harder than the witch hunt
is signing letters to parents of
soldiers that have been killed
i went to walter reed and i gave out
five purple hearts
to incredible uh young men for me it's
very hard when i see that
it's very hard strong words which is why
the media didn't touch it
whether you hate it or not trump's
decision wasn't impulsive but actually a
campaign promise
and reflects opinions going back decades
he's a miser with blood and treasure
you can call it misguided but at least
admit that it exists
but the media won't it's repetition 24 7
to avoid real truths about a new era
one in which we've seen the highest
household median income in history
punishment of china for oppressing
muslims continued prison reform
record employment for women and
minorities and now attempts to draw down
foreign wars
that the media finds such things trivial
says it all about the media
it's not hawks versus doves it's them
versus you
they can't stand you and i bet the
feeling is mutual
um i'm not going to admit to being an
expert on syria but i'm just very
suspicious
of how the line was drawn so immediately
dana that everybody had the exact same
thing
before the dust settled i think partly
that's because they were hearing that
directly from people who are there on
the ground who are in our intelligence
and military forces but why but nobody
mentions the number of troops you have
to like
pull that out of people you just
mentioned it
and three days later truth is i'm pretty
clear i was pretty clear that we had 100
150 people there and they were there to
help deter
the situation and commanders in chief
they have to make really tough decisions
and nothing is black and white these are
always shades of gray and it's very
complex
and the kurds should have known that we
were there
it was transactional it was tactical and
it was temporary however
any president knows that there is not
all decisions are going to be
um agreed by with all everybody else but
the decision-making process
should be one that can be respected in
this case it was
very hard to understand how it happened
all of a sudden and now he's talking
about mediation
he just said in the press conferences
walking novel now we're maybe going to
mediate but they lost
the kurds lost 100 people last night in
the fighting so
i i think that the critics of the
president on the right
they have his best interest in mind they
don't want him to have
to be criticized they want him to be
able to do what he needs to do to
fulfill campaign promises
and to do what he did we defeated isis
but the wii is very interesting
we had very few people there we had the
kurds were actually on the ground doing
the work for us and they lost 11 000
people and the kurdish leaders they also
have to send letters
to their people so when do you pull out
do you ever pull out jesse i mean the
fact is
this is a marriage of convenience
between america and the kurds
encourage you of a long-standing feud
with turks do we just stay there and do
we end up perhaps fighting the turks
um well listen i i think when barack
obama
pulled out of iraq he abandoned our
allies in iraq but the media
said oh that was a strategic
redeployment and then they cheered him
and then trump had to come in and clean
it up and bomb everybody and promise the
american people
he wasn't going to stay he's trying to
keep a campaign promise
i agree with dana alliances don't last
forever i mean we're allied with
saddam hussein we're shaking his hand
the next thing you know we're invading
his country and hanging him
i mean come on and then we pulled out
and left his people to die and we went
back in
and and saved the people again so this
happens all the time
um right now to say that we abandoned
the kurds i think is not really seeing
what actually happened
we let the kurds have a third of syria
they have the entire northeast of syria
where 90 percent of the oil reserves are
and all of the great agricultural land
we're talking about a very small section
right now and it's right in between the
pipeline that runs north to turkey
to sell oil to the europeans turkish
people they just want to make sure they
have that pipeline locked down
all i care about is we have the isis
fighters guarded in the prisons
and that's all i care about and if i was
the president i'd just ship them all to
antarctica
that's why i'm not president who's
guarding the prisons right now the kurds
who are being bombed by
turkey so the question is how are they
going to get in and make sure that the
thousands tens of thousands of
isis fighters aren't just going to walk
right out and as the president said
go to europe i mean that is a concern
and isis fighters going to europe
is a direct threat to the american
people we just indicted an isis guy
a month ago who went to syria trained as
a sniper and came back and was living in
brooklyn
planning additional attacks in the
united states so you said alliances
don't last forever
that is true the alliance with turkey as
a member of nato has to be looked at
because
turkey told the president that they
wouldn't be bombing civilians
as they went into this they've already
killed civilians in the last day
they said they wouldn't go after the the
kurds they're doing that they're bombing
hospitals
and they're not holding up their end of
the deal so i'm just a little bit
confused about the president's statement
that he wants to take
troops out which is fine that's
something he said he would do
consistent right but it's inconsistent
with what he just tweeted which is
well if the kurds are getting
slaughtered by the turks then we can
use a military option and send thousands
of troops in and if you're of the idea
that you do not want american forces to
be deployed on the ground
you have to have alliances on the ground
and it the turks did some things but the
kurds did more
when it came to fighting isis and i
think 11 000 dead kurdish fighters in
terms of how small their population is
as a pr and giving them the land that
they were occupying is a pretty good
deal considering what they did for us
and and limiting the attacks that
happened on american soil as a result of
that
let me just jump in real quick and say
that i just disagree with the premise
because i don't think this is the media
versus trump on this issue i think we're
hearing right here at this table people
who are not
members of the mainstream media no the
mainstream media
saying things that are very smart and in
opposition to the president's policy
and i also think therefore it's much
more the case that you see people
even pat robertson and i don't think
he's a member of the mainstream how do
you believe pat robertson
no i'm deciding pat robertson for saying
that trump is in danger of losing his
mandate of heaven if he permits the
slaughter of the kurds
and so what you see is that republicans
including lindsey graham right
on capitol hill a friend to the
president saying this is wrong this is
not surprising and using the word that
you say is so bad for them
abandonment they're using the same word
to my mind what you're seeing is not a
matter again
of some kind of partisanship this is
about a policy decision that people find
objectionable you said oh well it's only
a few people being moved but greg
the reason that it's a big deal is if
they if turkey had attacked an american
or killed an american
we'd go to war so we move our people
that's cleaning the door so that's why
they're there allow me to finish
and so we move our forces out of the way
which essentially gives the turkish
the opportunity to go after the kurds
that's the problem i just think the
question about turkey is
whether they belong in nato there should
be serious consideration about kicking
them out when they are
detaining americans and slaughtering the
allies of americans there's a big
question about
whether they should be in that alliance